[Музика]
No youngja livid minute ashkali the
absolu blue oh yeah yeah тому що після
фільму темрява романіст Traverse
хтось із Telstra особливого класу ой
лайно кажуть жовтий бичачий Коля ти
віриш заклад коханий Алі Алі синє
лайно кажуть, якщо не прийде  там,
Небраска каже ні так, я до джапа
Інженери Hinault з Нала Пассаїк називають,
що кісткова міязма зараз
колеса Томаса журчали, бачили бавовна Пітер
котлети політичний штурм Китай із Китаєм
відновився в тотемі Ла-Крос з
моменту chillwave cell і продовження
виборів у Китаї, який Takeshi Sakamoto  досягти
moksha
tides привіт, хлопці, мене звуть Наталія ochco, настав
час для уроку англійської мови, давайте почнемо, і
я хотів би привітати мого дуже дорогого
гостя сьогодні
привіт Оксана привіт як справи сьогодні я
добре дякую
добре сьогодні ми поговоримо про
Лондон  Великобританія Англія Уельс і всі
ці речі, які ми збираємось у особняки, тому
я хотів би запитати тебе, о Анна, ти
була в Лондоні ні, ти б хотіла поїхати
так у  це чудово, а
ви б хотіли поїхати до Лондона,
тож давайте подорожуємо Великобританією,
ми сьогодні зіграємо в гру, щоб ви пограли
з нами
у запитання, на які іспит забере,
щоб ви відповіли, і зберіть бали, які я
Я відповім собі, і я також
збираю бали, тому
між нами буде битва, добре,
давайте, я напишу імена
Наталія та Оксана, подивіться сьогодні, у нас
є чотири різні категорії, у нас є
Лондон  тож питання про Лондон у нас
є земельні питання загалом про
країну, а потім про погоду, тому я думаю, що
очевидно, ми поговоримо про погоду
та спорт чи знаєте ви всі слова
Оксана так добре, тому, як бачите, у нас є
різні частини запитань із
100  до 400 це легко 100 це легко
питання 400 є складним, тому давайте
почнемо з простих питань, погодьтеся, так яку
категорію ви б вибрали, можливо, для мене
спортивний спорт, тож давайте розберемося,
скільки від 100 до 400 100 100 давайте
займатися спортом 100 і у нас є  питання, тож,
будь ласка, дайте відповідь на запитання, що
звинувачують британці сміються та двічі
запитайте Оксану, що зробило, це сквош, сквош,
добре, що ще
футбол добре теніс так і добре,
кад так, так що футбол і крикет вони
є найпопулярнішими іграми у Великобританії, тож
якщо ви відповіли правильно  ви набрали 100
балів, а Оксана також 100 балів,
так добре,
мої вітання, давайте підемо, де мої
гроші, пізніше,
не хвилюйтеся, тому я виберу,
давайте з землею добре, і я
виберу 200 запитань, ви не проти
тож подивіться на запитання і допоможіть мені
Англія в 74 рази менша за США
, правда чи неправда, що ви думаєте, чи
можу я допомогти мені, що, на вашу думку, трюфелі
можуть бути правдою так це правда Англія
мала в порівнянні  зі США, так що
це правда, і якщо ви відповіли правильно,
ви також отримуєте 200 балів, добре зроблено,
давайте перейдемо далі, подивимося на файл фактів,
так що площа Англії становить понад
130 тисяч квадратних кілометрів, але
площа  Великобританія майже вдвічі більша
це близько двохсот сорока трьох
тисяч квадратних кілометрів давайте так
оксана правда тоді ви категорія будь
ласка причина добре скільки 200 200
давайте так подивіться температура
зазвичай нижче нуля у Великобританії
взимку правда  або false
нижче нуля у Великобританії подумайте про це
правда чи неправда,
можливо, неправда так подивіться на
відповідь температура не опускається
нижче нуля у Великобританії дуже часто
іноді це залежить, але зазвичай ні
мм-хм, добре, тому 200 балів йде на  Оксана
Оксана Ірина так Оксана
чудово, якщо ви відповіли правильно, ви також
набрали 200 балів давайте я
заціпенію від землі 100 добре ми говоримо
Великобританія або Великобританія і маємо на увазі Англія
Уельс і Шотландія B Англія Уельс
Шотландія і Північна Ірландія і C
Англія та Північна Ірландія, що, на вашу
думку, є правильною відповіддю a B або C, тож
перевірте, що ви думаєте, хто a, можливо,
так, можливо, прагне, тому, коли ми говоримо Британія, ми маємо на
увазі три країни Англію Уельс і
Шотландію деякі  Ви можете сказати, що
metalia B є правильною відповіддю «
ні», коли ми говоримо Англія Уельс Шотландія
та Північна Ірландія, ми маємо на увазі Великобританію
загалом, тож це різниця, добре,
ви правильно відповіли, і я відмовляюся,
це було моє запитання, вибачте, я набрав 100
балів для себе  давайте, моє запитання
так, оберіть категорію спорт,
безумовно, сто триста, це
дуже гарне запитання подивіться неправильне
дієслово gymnastics do like gymnastics yeah
я знаю, що так, це було
питання спеціально для вас, тому багато
наших студентів мають проблеми  із
запам'ятовуванням неправильних дієслів, тому ми
розробили гімнастику для неправильних дієслів.
Подивіться, у нас є різні неправильні дієслова,
як-от go swear win forgive me Prabha need
is clova, тому у них є три форми, які потрібно
запам'ятати так, так, і
ми збираємося їх практикувати.
різне привіт так, так
подивіться інфінітив - це перша форма ми
робимо руки вгору bidam я багата дитина
руки вгору так, це перша форма, як
g  o go for пішов так іди
хоча пішов, коли пістолет так три різних
телефони пішов зник, тому що три
різні всі вони різні
три причини, чому я пішов пішов gun
let's go було різне безпрограшно
повторити за мною так дзвонити один один один один
тому що  це тут, тому що це той самий
1-1 нічия зрадника з плювки bedight
давайте зробимо це ще раз
виграємо один Браво давайте зі словом
сумний сумний сумний сумний тому що це те саме
добре давайте завжди прощайте прощайте
прощайте прощайте прощайте прощайте прощені так
давайте  спробуйте ще раз
пробачте за гея пробачте добре добре зроблено
давайте спробуємо прийти як дуже гарне
слово прийшло прийде, помийте
папери зрадника - добре
добре дякую, я сподіваюся, що ви також
тренувалися з нами, і я даю вам
300 балів
добре виконано  Оксана, що було справді
важко
добре, дозвольте мені розібратися, чи 100 давайте
спробуємо,
то будь ласка, назвіть слова, щоб описати
погоду, що ви пам'ятаєте,
добре зроблено, що щодо Йоркського Санта-Клауса, що
ви пам'ятаєте погода слова можуть бути
сонячно гарно  дощ, добре, так, подивіться на
ці зображення, тож давайте подивимося на
це зображення, наприклад, у нас є
сонце, і ми бачимо хмари, які ми називаємо такою
погодою, мінлива хмарність, чи
можете ви повторити іммігрант-
поштань  мені мінлива хмарність до мінлива хмарність
Браво і вам, хлопці, дуже дякую
номер три дощ ви - так і
останній ні син не мінлива
хмарність тільки хмарно хмарно
так хмарно і як щодо цієї погоди,
що ви думаєте про
штормовий, ми можемо сказати  stormy stormy так ми
бачимо блискавку і ми чуємо, як
стоїть мій нижній обеліск qu qu mo
rim, тому погода штормова
дуже багато 100
дістається мені і вам також ми
чудова команда, давайте рухатися далі, тож ваша
черга вибрати категорію Лондон
Лондон скільки 100 100 добре, тому
подивіться на запитання хлопці в 2015 році Лондон
був названий найпопулярнішим
туристичним напрямком у світі вперше
правда чи неправда,
що ви думаєте, Оксана,
о, я думаю, що мій ведмідь падає, так, ви
абсолютно праві, тому що в 2015 році
Лондон був названий
найпопулярнішим туристичним напрямком у світі в п’ятий
раз за сім років  Ви
не вперше вважаєте, що це
найпопулярніший атракціон, багато людей
ходять туди, а тепер кордони закриті,
тому ми можемо просто пройти
презентацію, щоб відвідати Лондон, чому ні
добре, ви правильно відповіли я даю вам
100 балів добре  для мене, давайте, тому я
також піду з Лондоном, я
виберу 200 питання, давайте потрохи,
добре, так що ви можете побачити, подивіться на
картинку, це Тауерський міст або Лондонський
міст,
так що на нашому мосту ступеня так так багато
люди плутають це і називають це
Тауерський міст Лондонським мостом, тому що він
найпопулярніший, але це неправильно,
давайте подивимося на файл фактів.
dge на Темзі
та має дві вежі у вікторіанському готичному
стилі, які з'єднані двома
пішохідними доріжками, які сконструйовані таким чином, щоб вони
могли протистояти горизонтальним силам від
підвісних частин основи мосту
кожної вежі, утримує машини, які залишають дві
частини мосту, щоб міст міг протистояти  дозволити
пропускати річковий рух під ним
Тауерський міст розташований недалеко
від Лондонського Тауера, від якого він отримав свою
назву. Переміщення вологи занадто сильно розділяє Тауерський
міст, навіть запевняйте мене, хлопці.
питання
так так двісті балів дістається мені, а
ви оберіть категорію добре
400 400
це гарний виклик давайте, що
неправда про Великобританію, її площа становить близько
243 квадратних кілометрів Великобританія є
дев'ятим за величиною островом у світі або
Великобританія  перший найнаселеніший
острів у світі, що, на вашу думку,
неправда, це неправда
номер один два або три три три так
правильно,
тому Британія не є першою за кількістю
населення  острів d, але третій за кількістю
населення острів, тому я даю вам
чотириста балів, і якщо ви правильно відповіли,
ви також отримаєте чотириста
балів, я багата людина так, Браво,
це дуже гарна відповідь, і ви не
боїтеся труднощів, мені дуже подобається,
хм  моя черга я піду зі спортом 200
давайте спробуємо так назвіть англійські футбольні клуби
чи знаєте ви якісь англійські футбольні клуби
добре, а що з тобою Оксана, чи пам'ятаєте ви
якісь футбольні клуби у нашому
густері Манчестер Юнайтед чи Челсі
арсенал Ліверпуль та багато інших,
тому що футбол дуже  популярний
у Великобританії, тому для мене 200 балів, і я даю
вам 100 балів, це добре,
тепер ваш час вибрати
категорію, моя правда полягає в тому, чи добре 400
добре зроблено, тому подивіться найсонячніша частина
Великобританії  можливі відповіді
на північне узбережжя Англії з урахуванням кожного
шквалу новин лише південне узбережжя
Англії жило лише ОС Брешія
або східне узбережжя Англії, тож
як ви думаєте, що є правильним і
сонце  найголовніше, моя дитина, правильно,
це майже очевидно, тому що сонячний
звук звучить так, тому я даю вам
400 балів, добре зроблено, це дуже хороший
маршрут, тому ми продовжуємо, у нас є Лондон 300,
це буде мій вибір, давайте
назвемо назву  річка Лондона, то чи можете ви
назвати річку гарною,
як щодо вашої сауни, як ви думаєте
, як називається річкова дамба так, ми говоримо,
що разів
Браво так 300 я розділю це між нами
добре
, я буду щедрим 150 на  я і
150 вам, але якщо ви відповіли правильно,
у вас є лише 300 балів, добре,
давайте йти далі, тому у нас залишилося лише одне
запитання в кожній категорії, тож яку
категорію ви б вибрали землю 300
добре, так що у Великобританії більше 1000
островів правда  /false Я думаю, можливо,
тому що багато різних маленьких островів можуть
добре, тоді один був на 1000 островів,
це неймовірно,
тому 300 балів за Йорк, sana,
молодці, дуже дякую так, я
щедрий вчитель, добре, і давайте рухатися далі,
хм, Лондон  погода і  спорт давайте
з погодною службою 300
балів. Щороку в Лондоні приблизно 110 дощових днів,
правда чи неправда,
як ви думаєте, звучить я знаю я думаю,
можливо, так, багато людей кажуть, що
це найдощовіша частина світу,
тож це так  справді молодці і
знову 300 балів, давайте поділимося між нами
добре, я повинен дати більше балів собі
, схоже, я програю, все гаразд, все
добре,
тому у нас залишилося дві категорії Лондон
і спортивний спорт, звичайно, сер,
давайте 400 балів і  питання,
яке спорядження вам потрібно, щоб грати в
крикет,
це дуже гарне запитання, так що як
ви думаєте, добре, але так,
подивіться на картинку, тому ми
можемо поспорити, що це те, але у нас є
м'яч і злий, так що це  палиці утворюють
злий Вірату,
і нам також потрібні рукавички, щоб захистити наші
руки, так що знову ставка на дзвіночок і зло, чи
можете ви повторити, будь ласка, я ставлю на уклін і
злий Браво дуже дякую,
і вони дають вам 400 балів,
і якщо ви  правильно відповів 400  вказує
на вас,
якщо ви відповіли лише битою та м’ячем,
ви можете набрати 200 балів, це
буде чесно, добре зроблено,
тому останнє можливе запитання
– Лондон 400 балів,
давайте спробуємо, щоб ви могли побачити наступні
сайти в англійській столиці та  у нас
є варіанти Букінгемський палац Великий
вибух Лондонське око та Ейфелева вежа чи
можемо ми побачити всі сторони Лондона чи
щось, чого ми не бачимо чи не
бачимо в Лондоні, як ви думаєте, що це
допоможе мені, можливо, сила  так, вони
відчували, що ми не можемо побачити це в Лондоні, де
ми можемо побачити це в так,
так, Ейфелева вежа в Парижі, це не
в Лондоні, але, як ви бачите, у нас
великий вибух у Букінгемському палаці і
Лондонське око, будьте обережні, ми не  t скажи
London Eye ми говоримо, що довге заперечення, це
дуже важливо пам’ятати про
статтю, зараз давайте переглянемо
файл фактів, подивіться, що це за зображення,
назвіть фотографії, це завдання для
вас, тому номер один повернувся у Францію
так, номер два  там Лондон все добре
, це дивно  g і останнє так, Big
Bang правильно, так що 300 балів добре зроблено,
це було моє запитання
добре, тому, як ви бачите, ми відповіли на
всі запитання, зараз давайте порахуємо, скільки
у нас балів, давайте попрактикуємося в наших
математичних навичках хм 201
200 це  це 500, тоді ми йдемо з 300 і
200 це вже 1000, добре 300 і
100, тому у мене є тисяча
чотириста, давайте розберемося з вашими цікавими балами,
тому 500 ще один 500 це
може бути 1000 разом 1000 і 500 добре,
скажімо, давайте  ось так це
буде 302, а до 100 це
вже тисячі, а що залишилося 300
300 і 400 2700 Вау, я вражений
, вам подобається так, тому мої вітання
та оплески вам враховують
ваші бали, які були б  добре, якщо ми
маємо ці точки в грошах прямо в
банкноті, тому я відкриваю свій банк, де це
яка ціна, добре, тож давайте переглянемо
деякі граматичні пункти використання артикля,
давайте подивимося, щоб там стаття
певний артикль з географічними
назвами, давайте почнемо  ми використовуємо ні  статті,
коли ми говоримо про мости, коли у нас
є власна назва та міст, як-от Тауерський
міст, тож давайте потренуємося в реченні
Тауерський міст або Лондонський міст. Тауерський
міст – це найпопулярніша визначна пам’ятка
Лондона.
Лондонський міст Лондонський міст –
міст Рамона так правильно,
тому ми також не використовуємо статтю з деякими
сайтами, як-от Big Bang Oh Buckingham Palace,
але Лондонське око або Лондонський Тауер,
тому Лондонське око, будь ласка,
так, Букінгемський палац, Біг Бен,
але їхній Лондон дуже дякую
з країнами, в яких ми не використовуємо статтю Англія
Уельс Шотландія Північна Ірландія Україна,
ми не говоримо, що стаття там добре, а
з містами та містами ми також не використовуємо
жодних артиклі, як-от ванна – це гарне
місто, а ванна тут не ванна,
це назва  міста,
так що знову лазня - це прекрасне місто, чи можете
ви повторити, лазня - прекрасне місто,
дуже дякую,
тому давайте переглянемо, коли ми використовуємо статтю,
перший варіант музеї  наприклад,
Британський музей, давайте подивимося на
речення Британський музей пропонує
онлайн-бронювання, чи можете ви мені допомогти
тут ми
використовуємо статтю там, ви пам'ятаєте, ми
також сказали США Сполучені Штати
Америки ми також використовуємо статтю вони
тут, тому навчайтеся у Великобританії та вивчайте
англійську Семмі, чи можете ви прочитати, будь ласка,
вчіться у Великобританії та вивчайте англійську, дякую
дуже це приємна акція для
наших підлітків, тому з річками ми також
використовуємо статтю там Темза
будь ласка іноді або траншея
траншея Браво
чи пам'ятаєте ви будь-який український
реверс дипбров дуже дякую і
океан і бачите Атлантичний океан поблизу
Атлантичний океан у вас є
моря в Україні Чорне море серіал
Чорне море як все бачать добре ми кажемо
азовське море вони бачать ой так дякую
велике так
нехай  я трохи перевірю Оксану, а ти відповідаєш
з нами,
так що ми скажемо Лондонське око або
Лондонське око Лондонське око Браво
дякую
і давайте перейдемо далі Британський музей Музей
Британського музею це те, що
Британський музей вітає,
це дуже приємно  відповідайте на C
чи використовуємо ми статтю про не припиняйте
зі статтями про бачення Мені подобається Чорне
море Чорне море – це море також дуже дякую, а
що щодо океанів, сер так, сер
Атлантичний океан фантастично
добре, давайте рухатися далі, наприклад  великий вибух чи
використовуємо ми статтю Великий вибух, Великий
вибух,
не Великий вибух, корали великого вибуху, а
як щодо країн, наприклад,
Англія чи Англія в О, Ні
Англії, але з Великобританії, браво дивовижно, і я
хотів би відзначити дуже цікавий
насправді для вас, наприклад, ми говорили про
океани чи знаєте ви, що є слово,
назва океану, яке складається з
трьох літер seas і всі вони
вимовляються по-різному, давайте подивимося
PG на Тихий океан,
тому подивіться th  e перша буква C ми
вимовляємо як Pacific, остання буква C
ми вимовляємо як COO the Pacific, а також у
нас вона тут, в океані, ми вимовляємо
цей корабель, океан, чи розумієте ви, що у
нас така сама літера, але ми вимовляємо
трьома різними способами, що Тихий океан
Чи можете ви відстежити сану там, Тихий океан,
фантастичний, дуже дякую, і я
чую дзвінок, це означає, що нам
потрібно припинити урок, чи
сподобався вам урок так, я сподіваюся, що вам сподобався
урок з нами наступного разу, коли ми будемо
говорити про  Україно, тож побачимося наступного разу,
до побачення
[Музика],
коли ти робиш протокол як процес
Шотландські балясини Espada колючий пензлик
покажи мені нового однокласника так - або
підлітки з атомом молочної кислоти приходять на те саме ім'я,
зустрічаються, коли ваші сім'ї приходять,
але, так, кнопка  яка авала нормальна
ні бавовна привела ні так casarosden їжа
Yakima хоспіс тисне атташе з
горошок mawa - Moo no - асептика якщо
вона видаляє шрам так Кейт кролик
Ramada Akita знаю повагу від m  у
географії ми будемо ключем до життя
національний ні клас так біля стіни в
лідерах клас
[музика]
ти